we will start with me
ask lat book it says 45 students which
food a free amount of all the red zones
in high point and our compliments and
ideas on colored race probably right
provided in counting all the flags with
our brains who came up with 480 flags
most of them being Julian ideas let's
take a look at what we did the most
popular type of ideas was business
followed up with recreation the most
liked business ideas were commercial
recreation that like go-karts Moses
theme parks ice skating rink mini golf
and rock climbing the most popular
recreation types of sports solicitous
and they were dance party nipple court
skate parks rugby stadium to Lincoln's
dodgeball crooked nips and pitch fitness
tracks indoor soccer scooter park before
this stages by baseball stadium and
indoor skating rink on this graph it
shows where we put all that all our
flags and what we they represent the
most flag ideas are on parkway east why
were you like these ideas we like these
ideas because they are all different and
unique platform kids like sporty ideas
because of our teacher and teacher mr.
day you know when you were little when
you were always asking for ice cream and
fast food that's why there are so many
flavors
well where we want to focus on I think
that some kids focus on cowboy is /
staff area the most because that was
near their home so they can go anytime
just in less than two minutes it had the
most room for the most bang kids just
didn't care where they put it as long as
I had the idea somewhere so as you can
say we made a poster here
for
welcome